he's only been in the job five minutes
but the new head of Xbox is already
making some grand promises saying the
entertainment features in the xbox one
while important can't compete with what
they have to do for core gamers I'm Ken
Robinson and this is the news in games
recently promoted Xbox boss Phil Spencer
has addressed one critical concern some
users have expressed since the xbox
one's launch speaking with kotaku
Spencer said the xbox one's
entertainment applications are important
but appealing to the core gamer is
really what he's after Xbox one is our
most important gaming asset to date we
want to make sure we're completely
focused on that gaming customer the core
gaming fan making sure of that that's
what I'm gonna bring to this position is
a focused on gaming for Xbox one the
entertainment features that we have on
Xbox one are important but those can't
come at a cost what we do for the core
gamer Spencer did not offer any
specifics regarding the way in which
Microsoft will court the core gamer with
the xbox one going forward but he did
tease that Microsoft's presentation at
e3 2014 this summer will be one gamers
won't want to miss and don't worry PC
gamers microsoft hasn't forgotten about
you either so it's that windows install
for steam us just yet the PC obviously
is a top priority for us as a company
Spencer said gaming on PC is incredibly
strong but we as a platform company can
do a better job in that ecosystem and
those are conversations Terry Myerson
and I are having almost daily about that
focus where you put off by Xbox one
snazzy entertainment features it's just
returned to the core gaming market
enough to get you interested to pick up
one of the consoles let me know in the
comments and for everything else on the
Xbox one just head on over to gamespot
com